i
[Música]
el buque insignia en el mar negro de
rusia el mosca va náufrago cuando era
remolcado en medio de una tormenta tras
un incendio en la noche anterior así lo
informó moscú mientras que quiera
aseguró previamente que el barco había
sido alcanzado por sus misiles el
pentágono señaló que se trata de un duro
golpe para la flota rusa
en un nuevo intento por combatir la
migración irregular reino unido- anunció
que enviara a ruanda quienes crucen el
canal de la mancha de forma ilegal el
plan que recibió un fuerte rechazo de
organizaciones internacionales y de
derechos humanos aún debe ser aprobado
por el parlamento británico ampliamos
desde londres
el gobernador de florida promulgó la
polémica ley que prohíbe el aborto
después de las 15 semanas de embarazo
incluso en casos de violación incesto o
trata de personas una decisión celebrada
por republicanos pero rechazada por
numerosas organizaciones civiles
analizamos en esta misión
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan la jornada soy
valentina torres sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos con información
de la guerra en ucrania el ministerio de
defensa ruso anunció que su buque
insignia en el mar negro el mosca va
náufrago cuando era remolcado en medio
de una tormenta la versión del kremlin
indica que el barco se hundió tras daños
en su casco causados por la detonación
de municiones para el ejército ucraniano
había señalado previamente que el buque
había sido atacado con dos de sus
misiles neptuno que produjeron un
incendio tras varias explosiones a bordo
de acuerdo con el pentágono el
hundimiento es un duro golpe para la
flota rusa
se cumplen 50 días desde que inició la
ofensiva rusa en ucrania y hoy el
kremlin acusó al gobierno de kiev de
haber realizado al menos seis bombardeos
contra edificios residenciales en la
localidad de climo ubicada en la región
fronteriza de briansk dejando siete
heridos de acuerdo con el ejército ruso
las fuerzas ucranianas ingresaron
ilegalmente al espacio aéreo de rusia
con helicópteros de combate y ucrania
rechazó las acusaciones de moscú al
tiempo que reiteró que se prepara para
una ofensiva a gran escala en el este
del país
durante 50 días de la invasión a gran
escala de rusia demostraron que el
donbass es el objetivo principal de
rusia es el donbass lo que rusia quiere
destruir en primer lugar
son las regiones de dones y lugares en
las que las tropas rusas están
destruyendo como si solo quisieran que
quedaran piedras sin gente alguna
polonia lituania letonia y estonia
exigen que rusia rinda cuentas por los
presuntos crímenes de guerra cometidos
en ucrania este pronunciamiento se suma
a un coro de voces entre las que se
encuentra el presidente de eeuu joe
biden quien pide que se intensifiquen
los esfuerzos para hacer justicia a las
presuntas víctimas de violación los
detalles a continuación
puede que los soldados rusos hayan
abandonado esta localidad situada a 70
kilómetros de kiev pero el trauma de
semanas de ataques aún lo sienten los
residentes de aquí anna cuyo nombre ha
sido modificado para proteger su
identidad es una de las tantas mujeres
que han acusado a las tropas rusas de
usar la violación como un arma de guerra
ella narra que fue violada por un
soldado mientras que su marido fue
asesinado cuando intentaba salvar la
serna
el soldado me tomo de prisionera me dijo
quítate la ropa o te dispararé después
de que los soldados se fueron de mi casa
encontré drogas pegamento y viagra
los desgarradores relatos de violencia
sexual a manos de las tropas rusas
parecen no tener fin la vecina de anna
dice que el mismo soldado abuso y mató a
otra mujer su casa convertida en
escenario del crimen está cubierta de
manchas de sangre
los soldados rusos me dijeron que la
habían violado y que le habían cortado
la garganta o la habían apuñalado y que
se había desangrado dijeron que había
mucha sangre
y la cercana ciudad de mucha historia
desgarradoras similares reses que
ocupaban que porque nuevo mucho esto fue
después de que los ocupantes rusos
hubieran abandonado mucha alrededor de
25 niños y mujeres de entre 14 y 24 años
fueron violadas una mujer de 25 años nos
llamó para que la ayudáramos
y su hermana de 16 años que fue violada
por esos rusos justo en la calle
thank you very much el lunes el
presidente de la strada ucrania una
organización de derechos humanos informó
a la onu de otros casos en los que 12
mujeres y niñas acusaron a las tropas
rusas de violación dicen que sólo la
punta del iceberg mientras rusia niega
las acusaciones
cambiamos de tema y continuamos en reino
unido donde el gobierno de boris johnson
firmó un acuerdo para enviar a los
migrantes que lleguen irregularmente a
territorio británico a ruanda esto
mientras se define su situación
migratoria o su solicitud de asilo la
medida aún debe ser aprobada por el
parlamento pero ya ha generado fuertes
críticas siendo calificada de cruel e
ineficaz
luisa pulido corresponsal de france 24
nos amplía desde londres
es un programa del gobierno que ha
generado polémica incluso antes de ser
presentado desde hoy la marina británica
ha iniciado el patrullaje de las costas
inglesas en el canal de la mancha para
frenar la llegada de barcos pequeños con
migrantes ilegales que está alcanzando
niveles récord en el país según el
gobierno sólo este miércoles 600
personas incluidos niños llegaron al
país por estas vías y se prevé que en
los próximos días con un mejor clima
esta cifra se disparara a más de 1000
por ello quienes lleguen al país a
través del canal de la mancha o por
otras vías por ejemplo en camiones serán
enviados directamente a ruanda para que
desde este país africano puedan iniciar
el proceso de solicitud de asilo si son
elegibles para ello este programa se
concentrará inicialmente en hombres
jóvenes y se aplicará para quienes han
arribado al país por estas vías a partir
del primero de enero de este año el
primer ministro boris johnson que
enfrenta presiones de su partido y de
quienes res al dar el break sí para
frenar la inmigración ilegal ha dicho
que esta política también busca acabar
con las bandas delincuenciales que todos
los años ponen en riesgo la vida de
miles y miles de personas solo en el
2021 28 mil 526 personas llegaron al
reino unido- de esta manera por el canal
de la mancha
esta política ha sido criticada no
solamente por partidos de oposición sino
por organizaciones de defensa de los
derechos humanos por cruel e inhumana
sino porque además será altamente
costosa para las finanzas británicas
desde ella los defensores de los
derechos humanos prevén que enfrentará
obstáculos legales y una oposición feroz
en el parlamento británico
en otras noticias los estudiantes
franceses siguen ocupando varios
edificios universitarios en protesta por
la segunda vuelta presidencial dicen que
no se sienten representados por ninguno
de los dos candidatos por los bloqueos
el acceso a algunas universidades está
restringido y las clases se darán a
distancia hasta el sábado veamos que
dicen los jóvenes en el informe de
gabriel coaching
ni maicon ni leo penn ese es el mensaje
de los estudiantes que se reunieron
frente a la universidad parís uno
sorbona ocupada desde el miércoles los
manifestantes se enfrentaron a la
policía que usó gases lacrimógenos para
dispersarlos sin provocar ningún herido
en la segunda vuelta a los clasificados
son macrón que tiene un programa de
derecha y marie le pen que tiene un
programa de extrema derecha y no son
programas que respetan mucho a los
estudiantes los jóvenes denuncian una
campaña política que deja de lado los
temas sociales y medioambientales en la
primera vuelta el 40 por ciento de los
menores de 34 años se abstuvieron los
que votaron mayoritariamente eligieron
al sonic - y se encuentran hoy frente a
un dilema una situación como con eso
electro hoy tenemos una situación en la
que decían votantes de jean-luc
mélenchon la mitad no se pronuncia votan
blanco o se abstiene 30 votarían por
emanuel macro ni 20 a favor de marín de
penn así que vemos que este grupo de
votantes está dividido no como bien que
se juntan directo aquí de división una
parte de los jóvenes indecisos señala la
necesidad de bloquear extrema derecha
incluso si eso significa votar por macul
yo creo que si la gente no se motiva
para ir a votar si los que se abstienen
no van a votar si la gente que se sintió
decepcionada por la primera ronda no va
a votar entonces marie le pen tiene sus
posibilidades de ganar esa es la razón
por la que debemos empujar nos unos a
otros y tomar esta lección en nuestras
manos y contrarrestar a marín
dependiendo del edex como elección tras
elección la candidata de extrema derecha
estrecha la distancia con sus rivales
por lo que es incierto lo que pase el
próximo 24 de abril durante el balotaje
vamos ahora eeuu porque el gobernador de
florida ron de santis promulgó la ley
que prohíbe en ese estado el aborto
después de las 15 semanas de embarazo la
norma rige incluso en casos de violación
o incesto y fue aprobada por el congreso
estatal a comienzos de marzo en medio de
una gran polémica conectamos con alix
carrasquel portavoz de florida access
network una organización que lucha por
la defensa de los derechos de las
mujeres bienvenidas france24 qué
significa esta decisión para eeuu y para
las mujeres de florida
pues esta decisión es algo muy fuerte
que está pasando ahorita las personas
que están aquí en florida van a poder
tener acceso a la huerto después de las
15 semanas esto es una florida desde un
punto de acceso muy muy importante en
eeuu especialmente para los estados al
lado de nosotros para las personas que
están que quieren recibir abortos
entonces es una situación muy difícil
las personas deberían tener el acceso al
aborto sin ninguna pregunta sin ninguna
barrera
y en este punto es es muy fuerte para
las personas es prioridad especialmente
para las personas alrededor que han
perdido el acceso ya que sigue luego de
esta promulgación hay alguna posibilidad
de frenar que la norma entra en vigor
en este punto ya la norma está en efecto
desafortunadamente a partir de a partir
del julio primero la norma va a estar en
el efecto
nosotros en florida access network vamos
a seguir luchando para asegurarnos de
que las personas que necesiten acceder
al aborto puedan tenerlo así sea aquí en
florida o en otro estado
lo único es que ahora las personas que
no tienen tanto dinero para estar muy
afectadas porque van a tener que viajar
afuera del estado y no si no tienen los
recursos monetarios va a estar muy
difícil
nosotros como las las fondos de aborto
vamos a tratar de hacer lo más posible
para poder
y hacer que ellas puedan acceder sus
abortos
pero nada estamos haciendo lo que
podemos y cómo puede influir esta
normativa en la discusión que se
adelanta a nivel federal sobre el aborto
después de las leyes aprobadas por
ejemplo en texas o en misisipí o en
arizona
si cada vez que una ley se te hace en
efecto en un estado otros estados que no
que sean más republicanos este
tienen como una influencia entre ellos
mismos entonces piensan que están
haciendo las demás leyes el problema es
que los estados rojos como los llamamos
aquí los estados republicanos van a
seguir haciendo estas leyes estamos
esperando que rovi weir que es el
derecho constitucional de los estados
unidos para que las personas puedan
acceder al aborto estamos esperando que
no no hagan nada de cambio pero hay una
posibilidad de que si en el futuro este
en el verano estamos esperando pero
ojalá que no félix a usted muchas
gracias por su análisis por compartirlo
con nosotros en france24
gracias y nos desplazamos hasta el
continente asiático porque en shanghai
la ciudad más grande de china millones
de habitantes siguen confinados debido
al brote de kobe 19 por la variante
omicron y en función de la estricta
política del gobierno de cero kobe de
este jueves algunos ciudadanos
decidieron desobedecer a las autoridades
que hacían inspección en sus residencias
y protestaron enérgicamente contra las
medidas en el siguiente informe de juan
pabló lucumí veremos los detalles
[Música]
[Aplausos]
entre gritos y súplicas piden que no se
los lleven
shanghai la ciudad más grande de china
que ahora es el principal foco de
contagio de kobe 19 en el país tiene a
sus ciudadanos cansados por las
restricciones de la polémica ley del
gobierno de cero kobe en la urbanización
de sant ignasi en el distrito de pudong
algunos residentes decidieron resistir a
las autoridades
lo que empezó como una desesperada
petición de los ciudadanos terminó como
una protesta de resistencia ante las
medidas gubernamentales y es que en esta
región las autoridades confirmaron a los
residentes del primero al 5 de abril
pero el incremento de casos diarios
continúa por lo que no se han
flexibilizado las medidas ahora los
habitantes denuncian dificultades para
abastecerse y piden que se les permita
salir de sus casas ese es el caso del
japonés yukiya no que se trasladó a
shanghai a finales de enero desde el 23
de marzo sólo ha tenido dos días libres
por el encierro
acude con sin tocar todo el mundo
intentaba acceder al sitio web de compra
de alimentos y la página no cargaba
estas condiciones continuaron y me
preguntó si me será imposible conseguir
comida
este jueves la metrópoli china registró
27.000 positivos por kobe 19 un nuevo
máximo de contagios que se registra
justo después de que el presidente jean
ping informará que el país debe
continuar con la estricta política de
eliminación dinámica del cob y 19
antes de finalizar esta misión los
invito a conectarse con directo américa
edición nocturna donde mi compañero
santiago lópez y yo nos acompañaremos
con todas las noticias el debate y las
actualizaciones de deportes y economía
desde este lunes 18 de abril a las 19
horas de bogotá quito y lima
fin del informativo volvemos en breve
[Música]